dans ce carton 15 tablettes numériques
seront bientôt transmises aux enfants
accueillis au sein de la maison de
l'enfance des yvelines elles sont
fournies par seine et yvelines
numériques premier opérateur public
interdépartemental
on gère donc pour le compte du
département vis-à-vis des collèges
l'ensemble de l'équipement en tablettes
des collégiens et donc nous avions un
stock prévu pour l'année prochaine et on
a décidé de libérer ce stock des
tablettes à destination d'enfants de 3 à
12 ans confiés à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance
elles ont un double objectif garder un
contact visuel avec leurs parents et
assurer la continuité pédagogique en ce
temps de confinement j'étais plutôt vos
satisfaite de voir arriver de l'aide de
l'aide pour les enfants effectivement à
suivre leur scolarité mais aussi pour
mes éducateurs les éducateurs de la
maison de l'enfance qui doivent
s'adapter tellement à la situation
d'enfants la scolarité le niveau d
scolarité adaptée aussi pour un certain
nombre d'enfants tout est sécurisé
notamment et on a accès à des
applications qui sont validées par
l'éducation nationale n'avait qu'un
ordinateur pour tous les enfants donc au
niveau de photocopier tous les papiers
qui avait pour tous les enfants
c'est vrai que c'était compliqué ça va
être beaucoup plus simple pour nous déjà
pour renvoyer et pis pour eux ça va être
une façon aussi plus ludique de travail
et donc plus motivant au total 1200
tablettes numériques vont être
distribués par scène et vie numérique
dans les maisons de l'enfance et les
ehpad des deux départements